in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
and with me in the green room this week
is her about Cantonese chief physician
at the fertility Center Berlin welcome
be in good shape how many couples have
you helped in your career to get babies
so let me say if look into the history
it might be more than several thousand
which we've got a baby at the end oh
there's a lot of people great good job
and great job yeah it is
so um we just saw a report about
endometriosis is this a common cause of
infertility it's quite common so if you
look to those female who get not -
cannot get their children by themselves
it is 30% who have had no materials but
the question is is the endometrial the
main reason or not but sometimes it's
the main reason but very often not it's
just a finding and you have to look for
the main reasons even if you would treat
endometriosis the infertility could stay
on it could stay on because
endometriosis in itself it's a general
disease because if you destroy the
endometrial this implants by laparoscopy
they will come back after two or three
years and then you have to find out if
there are any other reasons let me see
if they're bad sperm count or a hormonal
disturbance or whatever this you have to
find out as well so is there a primary
cause of infertility or is there always
many causes you have to rule out you
have to look to five situations the
first most important thing is what is
the age of the wife because the
fertility rate is depending on the age
of survived it's declining after the age
of 30 the second one is what is about
the hormonal profile of the female you
have to look for hormonal disturbances
you can do it by blood tests the third
thing is looking to the sperm counts
whether the there aren't enough sperm
and the motility is quite good of the
sperm the fourth thing is to look into
the fallopian tubes are the fallopian
tubes blocked maybe as a result of an
infection and the last one is - the
uterus itself and because a lot of
people have fibroids in the uterus and
that might be a main reason as well and
it
you divide it in the female and male
part it's nearly fifty to fifty but in
some cases about 20 percent of all the
cases we do not find a diagnosed so they
cannot get pregnant they are not
pregnant after one year but you will not
find the diagnosed so when you look at
infertility on a global scale its
infertility on the rise I don't think so
and let me say especially in Western
countries it's not on rise we have the
idea that about seven to nine percent in
Western countries cannot get pregnant
after one year although they have
regular sex you should have regular sex
one or two times a week and this is
seven to nine percent there are some
parts worldwide let me say Africa where
you have a lot of problems with fibroids
and the uterus and there the numbers
might be higher and this is because of
infections in the parts a lot of in with
infections and the fallopian tubes are
blocked but the fibroids are independent
on infections it's a genetic question so
what would an expert do when a couple
comes to you and says that they're
infertile so normally you have to ask
you lots of questions the first question
is how long do you try to get pregnant
but going to a doctor means normally
that you try by yourself by just having
sex for more than one year and then us
survive what about your Mensa period is
requiring all 28 days or a short or a
longer time then you have to to a sperm
test and then you have to do all the
song to look to the uterus and maybe you
have to examine the fallopian tube
that's what you do it takes not very
long time then you have a quiet good
idea about the problem behind dr.
Kennedy how big are the chances that a
woman can get pregnant after cryotherapy
well it depends on the age of the wife
and she did freeze the eggs let me say
if she was at the age of 25 and she
froze her eggs then he has a chance to
get pregnant of about 40% if you have
enough X let me see if he could freeze
ten to fifteen
eggs if she's in the age of 35 it's
about 30% and the older one ever only
20% so it's not a kind of assurance it's
not an assurance so if you do some
social freezing and say I will get
pregnant later on and yeah there's a big
risk that you will never get pregnant on
that's right and in that respect the
main issue in social freezing is too
good to do a good counseling because you
shouldn't get counseled about a personal
situation about the situation to get
pregnant now maybe in the age of 28 or
to postpone it to 38 what are the
chances if she started 38 they are not
that bad but the main issue is their
having a good counseling regarding the
medical reasons and the plaka social
reasons okay so back to infertility if a
couple is not able to get pregnant what
should they do after they had sex should
should they see the gynecologist or
should they go all reproduce yeah mainly
mainly gynecologist is first step and
the gynecologist make some general
examinations about the background behind
the problem but then very often they are
referred to a center of reproductive
medicine and let me say normally she
should have one year of unprotected sex
and then if you're not pregnant
you should go more into details about
the reason behind it and if the age of
survive is more than 36 you should do it
earlier because of what because of the
impossible lack of eggs because the
number of eggs in the life of a wife are
decreasing continuously and the
fertility rate is dropping down let me
say after 35 years of age so if you are
older than that you should start earlier
so it's not only because of genetic
alterations and the risk of disease is
40 no no no no and are they by any means
natural ways to enhance fertility
without going to the doctor well there
might be some obstacles the gates
optimal situation to get pregnant if you
smoke let me say if you just smoked you
decrease your fertility rate of about
20% that's quite a lot if you are obese
both soubise female obesity male obesity
you decrease your vanity rate so
step in counseling is looking to your to
smoking drinking is not that main issue
but also looking to the question of
obesity that you should counsel and then
you go into details so after all it's a
healthy lifestyle which is not yes yes
yes you have not to go into diet but you
should have a high self healthy
lifestyle what what about about being on
the pill for years and does this
increase fertility after you discontinue
the either pill know if he's stopping
the pill she can get pregnant
immediately but if she had before taking
the pill and hormonal disturbance this
for mental disturbance where we appear
again after stopping the pill so but you
can get pregnant immediately after
having the pill thank you dr. kent
initial being with us in the studio
today thanks so much
you